- My husband and I went on safari
and in a little hut was a gift shop
and they sold elephant-dung paper,
and I bought several pieces
and sent them to my pop-up
friends, the paper engineers,
saying, "Well, what are
you gonna do with this?"
And so Ed Hutchins, who
is just a great dear,
he made this for me,
"Thinking of you,"
this is an elephant made
of elephant-dung paper.
- That's really the circle
of life right there.
(laughing)
- That's recycling at its best.
I am Ellen G.K. Rubin
and I collect pop-up and
movable books and paper.
I think I wanted to know a body of work,
instead of a smattering of this and that,
something that I could sink my teeth into
and wanting to be an expert
on something was a goal.
I get contacted by scholars,
people doing their theses,
they come here, they do some research here
or they inquire of me,
because I literally get
it from around the world
of people doing research on the flap books
or on the volvelles.
I would go to a cocktail party
or a place, where I
didn't know many people
and people would say,
"Well, what do you do?"
"Do you work?"
That question was always answered,
"Do you mean outside the home?"
And I went to Yale Medical School
to be a physician associate,
most people call it physician assistant,
and then when I was
working outside the home,
I said, "Oh, I do
bone-marrow transplants,"
and they immediately left my side,
"I have to refresh my drink,"
or something, nobody wanted to know
anything about what I did
and so I quickly learned
to say, "Oh well,
I collect and write about
pop-up and movable books,"
and their instant smile, which
we call "The Smile Effect"
and they would say, "Oh,
I love those books."
When I have the opportunity to
talk to people about pop-ups,
there are three things
I want them to know.
One, they did not start in the 1970s,
the way these Random House books did,
and the earliest books and I
just showed you, one from 1547,
were not for children,
they were for adults
and they were used as instruments,
mathematics, astronomy,
astrology, and medicine.
This is from 1933, there
are text describing
what a woman can do to
be a better sex partner
and so when you say a picture
is worth a thousand words,
a movable is worth so much more.
To this day, every movable book
is handmade.
I tell a story of when
I was in first grade,
the class subscribed to
Humpty Dumpty magazine
and so it was for first graders.
and with scissors and glue,
you could make things.
And then when we got to second grade,
my classmates graduated
to Children's Digest
and I refused, because Children's Digest
didn't have things to make.
I enjoy doing this,
but I don't have the
skills that these require
and actually most conservators
do not have the skill.
I consider myself a cheerleader
and when I started collecting,
publishers did not put
the paper engineer's name
anywhere in the book. That
seemed to me criminal,
because it's not a pop-up
book without a paper engineer,
that's where I got the
idea that paper engineers,
and I didn't even know
the term at that point,
but paper engineers are the artists
who take the illustrations
and make them move,
and that they are puppet masters,
but they hand the strings
to us, the reader,
we are the ones who activate everything,
who make them come alive.
My son knows I collect elephants
and so he created this Build-A-Bear
and he sewed this little pop-up book
onto the elephant
and he created this.
- [Elephant] I love the Popuplady,
she's my very best friend.